nico with the musical intro today
musical ender here we go get it i'll
sing
a couple of boys sitting on the beach
with the podcast
[Music]
jake was drinking tea matt had a pledge
hurting
redhead peter 42 l nico played the
panhand it's just chill vibes with this
thing only
it is let's put me in welcome to jamaica
i wonder if that would work as a frisbee
yes it would definitely
sure would and a murder device
make a really pleasant sound as you hit
somebody with it but yeah yeah yeah
actually should we try that right now
should we try it live
live on the quarter cast we throw niko's
hand pan
at an unsuspecting wren with microphones
up close to see what it sounds like it
would be such a soothing death for you
though
you know out of everything would be the
chillest deck can you talk about the
thing that i told you not to do that you
were
contemplating that could kill you oh
no because i haven't decided if i'm not
going to do that oh ren you're not going
to do it come on don't do it i might
talk about it on the podcast so you
don't do that yeah it's stupid if you do
it what's wrong with talking about it
because i don't i don't want to spoil it
it's in the video
i don't want to spoil it only the truest
of taun's yeah listen to this yeah
okay okay so at some point in the past
nico we're talking about storage spaces
and nico said
i look forward to the day i'm
paraphrasing i look forward to the day
that i can swallow a
terabyte yes well guess what that day is
here
you can buy a micro sd card that is a
one terabyte
size and it's small enough that you can
swallow it so
the question is how toxic are they how
talk is yeah how toxic is it how sharp
is it
to damage your internal linings it's
stupid okay
first thoughts uh this thing
is made out of plastic and
bits of metal and there's a microchip in
there isn't there i mean yeah
it's a bunch of sharp edges one of those
things
one of those things can be lodged in
your intestine
puncture a hole in your intestine
and you could slowly die from it over
the course of days or
a week i mean he could go to the doctor
yeah yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't get to
that point
call it a penny once that didn't hurt me
it's a round one thing though
it's not gonna puncture your intestine
yeah
i you could go get surgery fair enough
but you could be a bad puncture and you
could die on the way to the hospital or
it could just pass through without any
issues or that
but why risk it
[Laughter]
dude that's like headline that's like
cbs news
influencer dies from eating micro
processing chip for de views for new
year's be
clear i haven't actually decided if this
is something i
actually want to do it was just a
thought that i had today when i was
researching this stuff i was like that
would make for a funny bit but then i i
that's before i actually consider the
ramifications of that sort of thing it's
all part of the creative process
okay my point here is you can fake it so
easily why would you do it
because just i don't like lying and if
anyone asks me if
did you feel i don't want to have to say
yes i did i'm ashamed for lying well
then you don't lie
and i'll just say no i was all fake it
was for the views
i got an idea yes we'll get a hog
okay we'll feed it to the hog and if the
hog dies we'll eat the hog
we'll eat the hog yeah so right
yeah we're still that's not it's not a
waste we're not being wasted and then
when you test it because
apparently pigs like they're similar to
humans with their intestinal and all
that other stuff so we'll test it on the
hog yeah
it sounds the higher than the ren
it sounds like a well-informed sign to a
good time i'm gonna look into this i'm
gonna like research this like what
how bad could it be to swallow a micro
sd card if anyone out there like
actually knows information on this leave
a comment down below about the old lady
that swallowed a fly right
i don't know why a flashlight sounds
like the beginning of a child i guess
i'll die yeah
yeah yeah i don't i don't know she died
[Laughter]
she didn't die from the that's how the
story ends
in the end she died she died of natural
causes natural causes
but she swallowed a fly days before she
died so everyone led to the conclusion
that she died from there once was a
child who lived in a broom
cupboard and then dumbledore was killed
by snape
what are we talking about what has to do
with the fly
to the end of the story i like the story
structure yeah
yeah a young man named luke skywalker is
growing up on tattooing when the death
star exploded
the end yeah uh
so i want to talk about onewheeling
really briefly yeah let's do it
nico and i along with some few others i
went on a one-wheel ride last night
it was safe we all are distancing we all
had mass and i will
die on the hill saying that one wheeling
is one of the safest
coveted activities you can do yeah it's
a cough circle beforehand
we're gonna get really close and talking
it's a ritual we've had for a while it's
a pre-covered thing we haven't wanted to
give it up yet
you don't even wheeling is safe well
then you need to justify that that's
safe
i'm just saying it's just i know you get
the coughs out and then you don't cough
again
yeah because people without contact
seeing us all here sitting on the same
couch you know without masks on it's
like first of all
tested all the time yes and we're all in
the same bubble for the most part like
this is like
i don't have any friends outside quarter
really we're like a family
that's not true at least friends that i
hang out with because the only time i
hang out with friends are when i'm
one-wheeling
yeah and the only people at one wheel
with are you guys
yeah so anyway we're on this ride last
night and it was a really fun ride
uh jake was supposed to come out that
was the whole reason why this ride
was created last night was so that you
could join us and you
said you you actually didn't say uh but
you were going to say
so listen so here's my philosophy on
this um
my wife said that i might be a
workaholic now i don't know
if that's true or not i just i've got
three kids at home
okay i work from home now most of the
time when i'm not here
when i'm here it's like my one
opportunity
to like have uninterrupted
think and work time and so i just feel
like
i didn't want to waste that on a monday
night
and then like feel like i didn't get
enough done while i was here
and utilize the work of the work
effectively
and then i thought this was going to go
a different direction you're like wow
i'm away from my kids for a whole week
no i could just sit here and just relax
and not have any responsibility too
responsible i
i don't know but if you want to go on
friday
i do okay okay all right i'm down to go
on friday because okay friday night's my
okay you're good i give myself that time
off
when the fire is lit sometimes you just
gotta let it burn you know
that's just that's true man like i i
don't know i'm feeling good right now i
feel like
there's a lot that i need to do and so i
just figured i'll just hop and get it
man you know just
get it done yeah yeah so another reason
why i brought that up is because my
friend
brendan floaty mcfly who won race for
the rail this year
when he fly is that really his name or
is that a no his name is brendan
his name is floaty his nickname is
floating i mean yeah
he deserves it yeah he won race with
yeah like yeah he gets to call himself
whatever he wants i guess
he tagged me on instagram today on that
trail
overlooking the soccer fields and he's
like there are a bunch of onewheel
tracks here
and he's like there are a lot of
wonderful tracks here
was that you was that you and i'm like
no i could probably not and i realized
who's
in that spot i was like it was us it was
me it's nice that our group has enough
notoriety
for something like that also such a fine
selection of trails that
others would acknowledge i love the fact
that i love that about one wheeling
though
i love that about the onewheel community
right now is it's like small enough
where
if you're doing it you know in any sort
of like professional manner
or or even just like avidly you'll like
immediately find out who
has one by you and you'll notice tracks
on the ground and it's like this hidden
tracks on the ground is the fun part
yeah i remember another time we went
one-wheeling
in griffith yeah and we're going along
we we identified two distinct one-wheel
tracks
not three not one two because one was
treaded and one was not
yeah yeah and at points were like wait
is this another is this another set of
tracks there's like
just you know what we should do we
should custom fab you a wheel
to like exactly whatever specs you want
and then when we when we actually mold
it we should have the cast
have your initials in it so that when
people see it on the dirt like it has ww
in it oh my god
so like an actual like tire tread made
of debuts yeah uh
yeah or like within the top of the stamp
you know like within the top of the
rubber pads
like there's like there's like the
letter or the actual tread is w's
either one yeah yeah it'll be like your
calling card signature
any tire makers out there wanting to
make one-wheel tires hey burris hit us
up
let's make a custom corridor tire yeah
you couldn't get away with crimes though
that would make that a lot harder if
you're one wheeling away from crimes for
that you need a revolver
yeah yeah take the shells with you yeah
and the wheel you gotta drag the wheel
around
i have been wanting to make a diy one
wheel though i'm about
at the point where i'm like it might be
ready you can do it
you think there's uh there was a kit
that came out recently
which is basically just sourcing all the
open source parts together into a kit
yeah nico you said that they got like
cease and desist yes because they were
selling the kit
right and some people got upset but i
just want to remind people
they were selling the kit and patents
exist for a reason to protect the people
who put the r d into inventing it in the
first place
so future motion has all those patents
that's why no one else sells a onewheel
because they've got that on a lockdown
however
that doesn't prevent you from building
your own onewheel
and there are there are enough parts out
there there's still such early days
that it's like not quite there for
something that i would actually want to
use but maybe sometime next year some of
like the
the [ __ ] box might be like good enough
that's uh that's
uh yes do we need to bleep that
it's a dustin hoffman barbra
actually it's called a [ __ ] yeah is it
it is
like the german aircraft f-o-c-e-r oh
anyway it's electronic speed controller
for controlling a one-wheel and
they're getting better but like the
batteries aren't high enough voltage yet
uh to work with the controller and yeah
anyway
is it easy to like so the the motor in
one wheel is a 1000
watt motor is it a thousand or is it 750
i think that v1 is 750 and this one is a
thousand yeah pretty sure
so the the kit was a 1250 motor 1250
watt like how
how up there is that motor sizes like is
that like oh man you're pushing it
there's like maybe a little bit more
it's like
we're like 5 000 now like where are we
in that
scale it's it's hard to say because you
can have a really high watt motor that's
smaller and it there's a lot of
different factors
that go into like motor sizes motor
power motor torque motor top speed rpm
and i don't know enough about that to
really talk about it confidence how fast
can these things go
really i mean i uh
a onewheel if you were just to set it on
like uh like between two chairs and put
like a weight
on the sensor to activate it and just
let it go it'll go at top speed and
that's 32 miles an hour
because it'll say in the app it's going
32 miles an hour
but that's a like your balance has to be
pinned perfect yeah on the tire yeah and
like no resistance so like the moment
you put weight on there that instantly
changes the
the dynamics so that just means the top
speed of that wheel spinning as fast as
it could possibly go is 32 miles an hour
yeah that's the fastest you've gone
you've wiped out when i've wiped out i
don't know
the fastest i've gone period is like
just shy of 25 miles an hour
let me rephrase that question across
your whole life what's the quickest
deceleration you've experienced
oh god for all
of you car crashes included well i got a
car wreck once
yeah it would be a car wreck probably
right yeah it was a pile up on
i-10 between santa monica and like the
one
broke your boosted board yes oh
yes right okay great this is great story
time right now so
i was uh i was visiting a friend who was
in town uh and we're driving home
after visiting and something happened it
was a seven car pile up on the freeway
the car in front just stopped for a
reason so we all like braked really hard
and i managed to stop in time
getting into like that little tiny
because it wasn't quite a shoulder but
it was like a tiny shoulder
uh between the car in front of me and
the median
on i-10 like this big like six-lane
freeway but then the giant suv behind me
slammed into me causing me to get
slammed into the car in front of me
between them i was jammed in and i broke
my window with my
forehead like slam and broke the window
i had a gash across my head
which incidentally like the next day or
the day after that we filmed that
microsoft
surface commercial yeah do you remember
that yeah because you guys were out
filming i think the battlefield commerci
uh battlefield not commercial uh
rush rush yeah uh so it's basically just
you and i holding down the fort we did
like that cavi dog kung fu video
yeah and like microsoft came by and we
did like that commercial and we were
doing talking heads next door
and i had this gash in my head dig up
that commercial you see this cut
yeah they tried to put makeup on it but
you can still see it yeah uh anyway i
had my boosted board in my trunk at the
time
and the car slamming into the the trunk
crushed the boosted board and of course
that was
you know heartbreaking because it
snapped the end of the boosted board
yeah this is like this is like hip hop
yeah yeah yeah
just like right underneath hardware yeah
like all of that right there just
completely snapped off and it was like
dangling there
yeah oh man uh but before i threw it
away
i didn't throw it away i actually
returned it to boost and they were very
kind and gave me a new one
oh wow kudos boosted yes they were very
quotes one wheel
we used it in darth santa so in darth
santa
darth vader opens up this brand new
present and it's a boosted board
and he lifts it up and he crushes it and
the end breaks off right
and that was the actual broken boosted
board from my car accident yeah
and we just swapped it in with a working
one yeah uh so
we started off with the working one and
then it cuts to the snapped one is it
and it was literally just me holding it
up in the air and rotoing myself
out yeah yeah so that was like a honest
legitimately broken boosted board not
visual effects
well well because i got random remember
how it was it like warner claimed
the ads um because it goes and they got
it
goes into music i love that intro that's
going on on vfx artists react on like
four episodes oh yeah wait what yeah
wait what is uh companies claiming
uh the episodes oh because
there there is the cinema soundtrack
in the background of some of the clips
uh the the one of the lord of the rings
one
where that shot where it goes down into
mordor yeah through the mines and then
yeah yeah yeah there's like the
background music and then the no motion
blurred
orcs yeah so um they're doing that still
and uh the thing is so here's the
problem with that
is when you submit a fair use claim
and then all they have to do is say no
it doesn't fit fair use we don't think
it fits fair use
then the next step is to uh
to to re to like restate your claim
but at risk of if you lose taking a
strike against your channel
um and it's just like
it's a lot of risk yeah it's it's now
all of a sudden it becomes like a
legally
risky scenario and i understand
youtube's part of it
but like when we're talking about
what is effectively background music
even though it's from the cinema
soundtrack
background music that's being used in
the back of a clip while you guys are
talking over it
to examine the clip for the purpose of
boosting that
form of media to the general audience
and reinvigorating people
transformative yeah it's trans well it's
transformative because we're adding
information to it and we're using it in
that context but then also
we're not taking away from the audience
for it we're
in fact encouraging the audience for it
yeah so people want to go and see it now
because they remember how cool it was
they don't want to they want to say oh i
saw that
on corridor so now i don't need to see
it over here
or because
or because i saw it on corridor now i
don't need to see it or i
i hate it now like it's all of those
we're we're lifting up the property
it's clearly fair use it's like right so
clearly fair use
and then they can just they can
literally just say no it's not
and then now the sudden it has to like
you have to now put your channel at risk
in order to stand your ground and fight
yeah and it's just it's just so
unnecessary and they
they just do it because they can is it
the
film studios doing that or like the
music music labels
yeah it's always the musical right okay
always we get this question
all the time visit quarterdigital.com to
subscribe to our own website where
that's not an issue
yeah no kidding uh i lost my train of
thought
so the music it's always the music it's
the reason why we do not react to music
videos yeah even though there are
lots of really cool music videos out
there with cool effects and whatnot
we i get requests all the time you do
two incredible music videos
yeah it's like oh you should react to
like this music video or you should
react to music videos in general it's
like i feel like i've answered this
question a dozen times
yeah uh that's like we just can't
because we did that michael jackson
video that one time and like
that video was hard hardcore
hard no yeah that's that's not monetized
for us that's for sure
yeah well let's try to be monetized by
them i thought it is like it's
it's not seeing the entire video by the
way
yes like that's the other thing about it
is just like
okay we use five seconds
of the background track which is not if
isolated and people heard that five
seconds
the other question you have to ask
yourself is is that immediately
identifiable
with the property which i'm associating
it with
now the star trek one or the star wars
one
a little bit more because it's the it's
the beginning of that and it's done
and it's right at the beginning of the
piece there's more of an argument there
but for the lord of the rings one
like it's it's it's random strings
it's not like the lord of the rings
theme yeah
exactly it's not it's and not any of
that
and yeah that's that's what it needs to
be in order for you to not
have fair use and all these other things
and there's none of them and it's just
and then they monetize the entire video
so now all the money whether that's
other clips in the video whether there's
other music in the video whether there's
other things in it all of it now i just
i just
you know they say fair is a four-letter
word in the law but i don't think it's
fair
yeah no it's not what is the legal term
for when
you are like you're altering a property
but it's like
in a negative way is that defamation or
is that something
ah no i mean it depends on the manner in
which you
negate it negate it yeah defamation is a
specific type
type of that okay um that's like where
you
uh knowingly make misrepresentations
to intentionally devalue something
so the vast majority of drama videos on
youtube yeah right
drama alert yeah um and then there's uh
you know there's a bunch of other forms
of that like um
so just depends it's like stealing
something like
stealing is not a real legal word yeah
he stole that
stealing's like a slang word she's like
well what kind of steel
is it larceny is it robbery is it
murder burglary did you steal their life
is it embezzlement is it like all of
those things are different forms of
stuff okay
wow so if a lawyer says that they're
going to get charged with stealing you
immediately know they're
not that rude yeah the lawyer says i'm
going to charge you a stealing yeah
okay back buddy i'm going to go to your
law school and charge
them with stealing uh stealing from you
to get your law degree
what's the crime you charge somebody
with if they stole your heart uh
dude uh i'm gonna shackle you with a
ring
yeah um i don't know man
probably something in latin you know
like uh respond yet superior or
something
that sounds official it sounds legit i
hope you're sitting at home
today enjoying the holiday season and as
part of the holiday season
i'm going to tell you about today's
sponsor story blocks now storyblocks
got together with santa claus he decided
that one day
he was going to do something nice for
the elves and the elves actually have an
av department up there at the north pole
and they said santa we make a lot of
toys we're making all these videos
but they're not quite complete we're
missing a little bit of something they
said santa will you please get us
a story block subscription for christmas
this year and he said well
what does storybox have to offer that uh
my magic
and my reindeer can't offer you and
they're like well santa
storyblocks is the one-stop shop for all
your video asset needs it's the complete
solution whether you're
an individual like me mr elf over here
or a business you know the north pole
the enterprise that is the north pole
it's perfect for all of those different
types of people because with an
unlimited all-access plan
you can download as much stock footage
b-roll
motion graphics after effects templates
audio assets whatever you need
from the site as many times as you need
everything you download from storybox
you can use royalty free for commercial
or personal use so
he went and he consulted with mrs claus
and consulted with rudolph and well they
came back and they said guys
here's what we're going to do we're
going to go to storyblocks.comcast and
we're going to get you a subscription
that was like wait
really you're really going to do that
and he's like yes we're going to go to
storybox.com
quarter cast to get started that's what
they did i know i i know i i can't i
couldn't believe it myself
but you know santa's real okay until
next time
enjoy your holiday so anyway i don't
know how we got on that but we were
talking about
the the craziest moment in your life
when you've gone from
the fastest speed to this oh yeah in the
shortest amount of time
um so actually ren yours is the other
way he went from the fastest to slow
speed to fast
you got accelerated not decelerated yeah
so you didn't answer my question
all right he's got to start this podcast
accelerated
faster than you've been decelerated
well he was hit because he stopped he
didn't get decelerated he got actually
how fast did you well you hit your head
and it broke the glass i mean that would
have been some significant deceleration
yeah yeah that right there
it's a brief moment after i accelerated
quickly
how fast is terminal velocity for a
human it depends it's about 120 miles
away okay so for me it's probably
skydiving then
no your quickest deceleration yeah from
the parachute
is that hard is that a hard yank kind of
yeah yeah yeah you decelerate pretty
quickly
i don't know maybe not it's it's
it's a it you feel it it would slow you
down very quickly yeah if you're talking
about going from
over a hundred yeah yeah i guess what
about like
those those fall things at like
fairgrounds
oh yeah yeah yeah or like yeah you know
drop yeah things you're like yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was happening pretty fast
speaking of acceleration uh chuck yeager
passed away i saw that
yeah oh see that face he was the first
guy to break the sound barrier that's
right
well wow mr chuck yeager yeah i played
chuck yeager's air combat a whole bunch
on my
macintosh performance when i was like
eight years old yeah
and the thing is like because back then
they didn't quite know how to like deal
with like licensing software and
shareware and all that kind of stuff
so you know you had like the ones where
it's like there'd be like civilization
back then like i think it's like
one or two like you'd have the manual
and be like flip to page 40
and tell us what's in the box like and
write the word in the bottom left corner
and so you have to have the manual
you type it in to the game and it'll
unlock the game for you oh gotcha
that's the way like making sure you
owned it you didn't just like copy a
floppy disk
and so if check yeager's air combat it
asks you trivia about airplanes that
were answered in the manual
such as like what's what's the height
from cockpit to ground
um of like you know this airplane and
you're like uh
i didn't have the manual i didn't know
the game get up back then i would guess
i actually guessed one of them correctly
at one point
and then wrote that down down because
they cycle through them it's like every
like tenth like
question or something like just keep i
could unlock the game and like play the
game like a dmv
license test
oh man i missed that era of software
security can you imagine like photoshop
or premiere
being like what's uh what's the european
frame rate man we used to
hack our way through some some code
sometimes like i remember when we
when we first started working down here
like in the party bucket
yeah and there would be all these
software programs in the party bucket
folder
and maybe it wasn't party bucket yeah
it's like
our stuff yeah all the hacked stuff and
i remember
like one time i was trying to set up
premiere or something or some other
program on
on a laptop and it was just it was the
jankiest
like situation and and you and sam were
both busy and i was like
guys how do i set up this hacked
software and i was like
and eventually i figured it out but
literally it took me like four hours
to like figure out how to unhack and
unpack and like
crack yeah this software program i feel
like imagine if i spent
four hours one day just trying to open
from here
yeah god i feel like we've all been
there most artists that we never talk
about it but we've all been there at
some point getting started when you
can't afford
pro software we got to learn it right
you can't get the educational
that's license or whatever yeah yeah
correct you gotta like you know
what else are you going to do i mean
there's an acceptable listen
even if even in like general society
there's like an accept i don't want
people to take this wrong way because
to use a legal term stealing is not okay
but like there's an almost an acceptable
level of like
no harm stealing that's inherent
in any like economic enterprise or like
any enterprise like in order for you to
to do it and to
understand the fundamentals of it if you
don't have some like wise teacher
who has all the tools and you
apprenticed under them you know
and they already own it all and yeah but
if you're like
kids just like figuring it out and doing
it for yourself it's like how else do
you learn
yeah you you have to do that do it that
way no one's got the 150 bucks
to do it you're you know like 10. you
just don't yeah
yeah and so you know
i i mean i learned a ton of about
computers from
cracking software right you know it was
such like a like okay this is how things
need to be installed this is how
directories work this is how like files
are written
yeah and like once you get into like the
more obscure stuff because there's a
bunch of software too that like
you know back then at least like if you
want to install some of the stuff you
had to
like it wasn't just a double click and
install kind of thing a lot of the
software was like really janky just
even if it did if you did buy it it was
still super junky yeah
but i feel like i learned so much about
like how to set up a clean environment
on your computer and be standardized
with it and eliminate
all those other variables and just boil
down to one single thing
one step at a time to work your way
through it and solve a problem
right and there were so many different
ways you could install
stuff especially back in the day like
with with like
what type of operating system you had
what sort of like add-ons they would try
to give you and like
all this other nonsense that you didn't
need that
yeah didn't really get you the core
fundamental function that you were
looking for and sometimes you could par
you could parcel out what types what
what parts of the software you wanted to
download
like no i don't need that one i just
need this the thing that does this
um yeah yeah that kind of problem
solving and troubleshooting is still
is useful now oh yeah i mean we have all
kinds of problems with adobe projects
and all that stuff requires that we're
like all systematic yeah kind of
troubleshooting
man you jumped to davinci resolve yes
this year yeah basically for the first
time yeah
yeah and i know you you heard me you
know with my gripes about it
up front i mean everything's got
everything's got some changes yeah of
course it does of course
but like now the more i'm using it um
especially for
more narrative stuff it seems like
that's just like the workflow especially
with like multiple people
um on a server with it is just like
miles better
uh for for what we need yeah the
workflow thing is huge
yeah and even now like there's some
premiere stuff that's happening
uh for vfx artists react that's like to
the point where
like i'm saying too like guys we should
probably probably get to the bench
man like this stuff is not going to
happen in davinci so you know
like even even in that workflow i think
it would be nice to try to get there
at some point um but yeah i it's
definitely like
yeah both especially right now
uh you kind of need to know what you're
what you want your end product to be and
what your workflow is going to be
yeah and like what your file types are
and all that stuff
because that's all super important in
that yeah
yeah i feel we're in a little bit of a
tricky spot like talking about the stuff
because like we have a really good
relationship with adobe and you know
we've spoken for them at nab
and all this kind of stuff but like i
have been
very frustrated with the software over
the past year or two mainly
like partially in terms of the stability
but you know in a way you get used to
that a little bit
sure but almost more so in the lack of
like modern features like
they are innovating they're doing some
things but there's also like
a lot of stuff like if you step back and
look at the industry and like the way
certain things are going
and they haven't like adobe hasn't quite
jumped into some of those
things that you would want them to be on
top of because you're paying a
subscription for it you know it's like
i mean the clearest example is the the
black magic uh pocket camera yeah black
magic raw support yeah
oh here's one of the most popular indie
cameras that's out there
and they didn't implement support for
the raw format
and you know i'm sure it's because they
don't want to somehow help
magic had to come out with a patch yeah
that you had to download and then
put on premiere and it only works for
premiere it doesn't work for after
effects
third party had to make a codec for
after effects and it's like why am i
paying the subscription
so you like so you guys can like use me
as your pawn and your fight with this
other company it's like no
yeah support the format like you're an
editing program you support formats like
i don't care that they also make an
editing program deal with it and
and service your customers yeah and just
make a better product then
yeah yeah and they i think it kind of
speaks the moment you start doing that
as a company i think it speaks the fact
that you are losing
yeah you know and maybe you got some
great features but like you need to turn
something around somewhere inside your
company if you are
that afraid of your competition that you
are withholding features from your
customers and doing so
yeah maybe there's more at play but i
gotta i gotta think that if some dude's
busting out like a plug-in for after
effects and premiere like one month
down the line on a toots.com or whatever
it is
you know black magic does themselves a
year later i gotta think that somebody
in adobe is going like
no i won't do it
so you know that really that really
soured me uh you know to
like how kind of they've been handling
things and then just looking at
you know flame flame is like one of the
oldest
compositing it's not the oldest
compositing program um it's like one of
the first digital effects
software's out there and they just came
out with uh some plugins recently in the
newest update that have some ai
generated tools
such as a ai generated z depth um
solution and they had generated uh
automatic like human cutout
yeah and a couple other things and the
fact that
adobe was about nine months later after
that to bring rotor brush two out
tells me that doby's being really not on
top of some of these cutting edge things
and rotobrush 2 is great don't get me
wrong but there are so many other
features that they could be
working on and adding into the program
based on just what i'm seeing out there
and they got stuff like you know like
the smile tool which adds a smile in
photoshop using
neural networks it's like a better
camera tracker what's that i want a
better camera
i want an actual 3d interface in after
effects that's not
20 years old does the smile tool make it
look people look super weird oh yeah
it's a novelty tool like
parents are coming into town and we have
this really special photo that we took
of like him and jenna and like it's like
a really important photo
it's like your guys's five year or
whatever and we're gonna give it to your
parents to like commemorate the fact you
know that their son is like a man now
right and you can do something just
really really in-depth
backstory
you like pick them up from the airport
and it's like you know you just drag it
out
and drag it out and they get to the
studio and you're like give it to him
and it's like
these cheesy photoshops the dogs are
smiling with human teeth
that's always so funny when you put
human teeth on animals because
because you can't see it right away
you're like this looks immediately
weird as hell and terrifying at times
but you're not like immediately like
what is wrong and then you wait for them
to say something and then eventually we
give them the real one
which is like the real gift but like you
let him you let it hang in that moment
where
your mom is trying to say something nice
about it yeah you know
super serious huh
y'all are really smiling and that
dogs seem really happy you like have it
fit into a really expensive frame for
like the the atrium of their house
you know like the entry of their house
do you remember
oh my god remember that one
demonstration they did with uh
um jordan peel i think it was um
it was like three or four years ago and
they took audio and they showed him like
how you can spice audio but you can also
have it analyze your audio and say
something that you didn't say to film
the gap do you remember that
demonstration they did with him
um it was like one of the like adobe max
conferences or something like that
it worked really well and he's like whoa
and they've never released that
they never put it into software and i
don't think it's because it didn't work
because it already worked on stage there
and
we've seen plenty of demonstrations
there's usually a two to three year uh
period between when they announced
something at adobe max and actually gets
rolled out as a feature yeah this was
announced
pretty far before it was in 2012
actually
it's getting it's getting maybe
struggling
yeah how do you think that they held it
though because of
the implications of being able to make
people say things that they didn't say
i i don't know i i i find myself
doubting that silicon valley doesn't
care about ethics
you're right they just pretend that they
do when it benefits them yeah yeah
yeah okay i take them back yeah i'm
ramping speculation i'm cutting it off
like if they could have released that i
guarantee you they would have
you know it's like like look at what you
could do look at all the damage you
could do to society
have fun yeah i mean that doesn't bring
up the conversation that you hear all
the time like deep fakes
a danger to our democracy it's like guys
everybody visual effects have been
around for a long time
deep fakes aren't the beginning of it a
danger to our society i mean i said the
same thing about television 3d
animations danger to our society but
it's like
you still have to be a vfx artist to get
a photo really photographed
and deep fake yeah you know it's it's
just as much work to get a photo real
deep thick as it is to use like any
other numerous methods out there to fix
something
hey mom how you doing i'm working real
hard over here becoming a danger to
society
i've learned a lot it just seems easier
because it is more computer-based
it goes back to the whole reason why
visual effects artists don't ever really
tend to get that much respect because
most people are just like you just
press a button and then the computer
does the work for you and
that's obviously not the case but with
deep fakes it's a little bit
more the case yeah because you are
telling a computer all right
now train and then you come back after a
day it's done 200 000 iterations and
it's like wow that looks pretty good
good job computer it was also like a
i'll name you petse
but what nico was saying is it requires
so much work just to take it from that
to actually be composited like into a
shot and actually
blend well and and look right there's so
many different
like tiny things that a visual effects
artist has to do to make it work yeah
everything from like the reflection in
the eyes to the blend at where the chin
meets the neck you know
not to mention the whole like acting and
everything i think one thing that just
like hits people so hard about defects
though is that it's
a mask it's a digital mask it's an
amazing digital mask that
makes you look like another person and
there's just something about masks that
like inherently like
hit us and like make us like connect
with them and like oh man you can do
anything with this mask look how real it
looks it's like yeah
it's you could like have a realistic
looking mask and that's about where it
ends
[Laughter]
unless you put a lot a lot of work into
making it perfect it's going to have
that uncanny valley effect
yeah well because you also have like
like uh like facial shape and body shape
like there's that one
uh deep fake video with like the round
table of all like the famous people like
robert downey jr like george lucas
and you saw that one right mm-hmm yeah
and tom cruise was there the tom cruise
uh
actor evan yeah uh was in that video and
some of the defects were pretty good
but like it didn't matter how good they
were because the person just
didn't match the body shape at all and
you're just like this is weird now
because it's like
when did george lucas lose 180 pounds
like yeah
yeah the guy who did that was actually
one of the guys i worked with at the
south park
okay is that something you can talk
about now kinda okay
well the stuff that's released because
it's released well yeah um
so i think i mentioned in this podcast
maybe not i never really
said it on my instagram and stuff but
like i thought this was still a secret
not really no um so there was a
a deep fake project that i worked on
with the south park team uh you know
train matt and those guys
um they put together a group of uh
artists
uh various deep fake artists and made a
new company that which is called uh
deep voodoo and basically this company
is built with the intent
of bringing uh deep learning based
visualizations to market so right now
deep fakes for the focus but there's you
know there's obviously other things you
can do with a computer outside just
right you know generating deep fakes
but you know they have a super creative
team there and
you know what better use of like easy
caricatures than to put it in the hands
of
matt and trey and peter serafinowicz
also um who's working with them on it
and so i was brought on as well as a
couple other artists and
like very early on yeah very early on
this is actually right at the beginning
the pandemic
um and worked with them on
developing deep fakes and defect
techniques and just
actually doing shots and delivering
shots for this shorts which is actually
on youtube you can go watch it right now
sassy just sassy justice fred sassy of
cheyenne wyoming investigating the top
crimes and the top
crazy stories i've been sent that video
so many times to react to on vfx
artistry act i'm just like
oh you have no idea i have no idea how
you can react to that [ __ ]
so they dropped that uh and it's on
youtube you can go watch it um
and you know it's cool i was part of
that thing you know i got
i got to work with a bunch of super
talented people and
my favorite is cheyenne dialysis
is so funny yeah dude the dead mark
zuckerberg
that's probably the height of what we
can do with oh yeah yes as of right now
that's the best that's the best
so voodoo is the best deep fake team i
mean it's made of the best
phenomenon in the world it's phenomenal
yeah but that still kind of brings me to
my point earlier
where it's like there's still an uncanny
valley effect like you still
know that that's not trump like even
though it's perfect
it's still like it's still obvious that
okay this is a deep fake it's a
fantastic deep fake yeah but it's you
know this is still a comical
take on this we're fooling ourselves
like you're talking about
uh what a hundred thousand year well
however long mammals animals are humans
no humans sorry fifty two hundred that's
a rough start to that sentence
for however long human humanoid primates
have been able to examine each other's
faces and interpret all of these things
like
what type of emotion you're feeling your
sincerity levels like all of these
things that are just inherent that we're
processing
all the time and to like say oh and
in like a year and a half of working
with this technology we're gonna like
you know fool everybody yeah i think
it's a little bit ambitious
i will say i was surprised at how
not much of a deal deep fakes were
leading up to the election
like i don't know i kind of just
expected to see a lot more stuff kind of
coming out
of like actual male content or misuse of
deep face trying to like what are you
gonna do with it
like oh here's trump shooting a child
it's like
i don't know i guess i didn't know what
to expect i just expected there to be
something
and then there wasn't yeah it was like i
mean other than sassy justice
which kind of covered all the bases but
like
that was that yeah but like i don't know
i
i was i guess i kind of just found
myself being afraid like maybe someone
will figure out how to like misuse this
and they're gonna do it to like sway the
election somehow and then like literally
nothing came from it yeah so it just
kind of reinforces the point that it's
like what we've been saying is like well
i mean
i mean people don't even believe things
that are true so like
how do we get people to believe
something that's fake yeah you know
maybe there was and we're just like
that's nothing we're not in the bubble
you know it's like sure
maybe it just didn't hit our circle yeah
true and then the the amount of like
fake information that like in the way
that it gets developed i mean there's
some pretty
real scandalous stuff that happens and
um i just think there's also like if if
that's what you're
if you're that thief and you're looking
in your toolbox and you're like how do i
come up with misinformation
for this you know it's like
all you need to do is like drop one
piece of wood into the fire and like and
then it just goes
that way and you have so many different
tools to do that with like
yeah even just recently with some of the
stuff that was going on i won't get into
exactly what it is but there was some
misinformation that was out there
and uh and i was kind of tracking it as
it was developing and it was
crazy to me like it was so crazy to me
to see
firsthand like how something that we
were directly
like next to knowing that knowing the
actual facts
how how how crazily that got
misinterpreted and taken and construed
and just like
along into like a thousand different
directions what happens all the time
like we were talking about uh
that one bar owner in la that you know
made that protest over the
yeah next to her yeah and this is on the
la subreddit
um so you post that and all the comments
below
yeah everybody on a film set gets tested
every day they have coveted officers
walking around they're not oh i know
what you're talking about yeah
you literally have to sit in a glass box
in a plexiglas box when you're not
touching anything on the set and then
when you touch the set
somebody a pa comes in after you with
[ __ ] hand sanitizer and like
disinfectant spray
and like cleans everything you just
touched and then you turn around and you
go back to your box and you sit there
until your knee is on set again
like that's literally how union shoots
are being run right now
wow so the ali subreddit you know
there's a lot of film people in there
like explaining yeah i work on a film
set this is like way locked down
it's a very different scenario than a
bar there's a reason she shut down
and the the launch tents for a film set
aren't shut down
but then it gets posted on another
subreddit blows up hits the front page
and it becomes
well looks like so you got to be
connected if you want to keep your
restaurant open because she's getting
[ __ ] on by the big guys like yeah the
narrative gets completely spun
and just it's it's a little bit of a
chilling reminder of like
this is this is the side effect of
having decentralized information to some
extent but also a bit of a side effect
of people's media consumption being tied
to like you know like profit being tied
to eyeballs you know there's a reason
like facebook and reddit and everything
else they want
they want that views they want the
outrage they want the drama they want
the emotion because that just means more
people and more engagement more
discussion
and there's a light pass at like it
needs to be truthful but we'll let
people figure it out on their own
yeah it's completely decentralized and
then it's and then it's
and then the reinforcement technique of
like hey what should we make more of
isn't based in uh anything but other
than what gets
views it's it's i i don't understand
right now how there's not a a huge push
by congress
to to come up with some form of like fcc
type regulation here it's just i don't
know how much longer we can go
on without it to be honest like
when when broadcast came up and they
were like
wait a minute anyone can get on these
airways hold on
you know and they were like hold hold up
hold the phone
okay not we can't just be having anybody
with a radio
antenna putting out signals okay and
they came up with the fcc
to actually come up with rules for what
you could say and do
on these open airwaves these open forms
of communication
but because now that law it
doesn't directly apply to this new
technology now all of a sudden it's like
exactly what was they were intending to
not have happen
right now is happening which is just
like complete decentralization
anyone can hop on there and say whatever
they want and there's no
truth-based
regulatory responsibility that's
happening either from the private
companies or from the government right
now yeah and there's outrage from it
when it does happen like i mean
you know twitter right now has this yeah
and then they come out and they're like
the government's gonna take
away your twitter free speech yeah
it's like what no like guys maybe just
yeah well that's why you know i think i
figured it out that's why
we're probably not gonna really see deep
fakes be a thing because
why do something so complicated when
simple words are not right
that's exactly what i was getting at
yeah like you can literally just say
something and then all of a sudden it's
like
there you go you need to buy some words
in the right
spreads it's so easy to share right yeah
yeah
so it's ooey it's yucky
so you know what take your time to be a
critical thinker
take your time to do your research take
your time to see things from multiple
points of view
try to understand everybody understand
that we are all people
are working towards the same goals just
figure out the context with which the
other person's approaching it from
and let's make the world a better place
one at a time with our own individual
actions
because that's the best you can do
heavy [ __ ] fee
[Laughter]
wow so anyway um
i mean i gotta get going because i gotta
go home and
eat dinner with my baby yeah yeah so
guys i'm still online dating
i'm gonna make my la cafe order uh right
now
yeah be here in about an hour i've been
at yellow cafe in a long time
oh hey they got the new okay you guys
are la downtown or wherever their other
locations are there's a few in town
they've got that new new nashville type
seasoning
on some of their chicken oh it's like a
draw it's like a dry rub but it's not
and
it's like spicy but it's just spicy
enough yeah you talking about la cafe
yeah
i don't i don't know anything about this
by the way sun all right cafe ella cafe
is a standby it's like yeah before
before postmates there's only one place
yeah that would deliver
anywhere quickly and easily yeah 24
hours a day 27 days a day
you want some fried chicken at three in
the morning you got it son
you got it i mean wow yeah it's it's the
indie film shoot stand by you can shoot
a music video
and your three friends like out like
stealing some shots on the train track
yeah like
ellie cafe the guy that the guy that
delivers here he's delivered here a
couple times and you can tell like
he's delivered la's a very diverse place
by the way like
and through as a result
of this like diversity of like all these
people from all these different walks of
life like just meshing into the same
spot
sometimes people become very mechanical
when they're working in like a
professional job
and so he this guy you can tell how many
people he interacts with and how many
times
he has to call on the phone and say hi
i'm from la cafe
i'm outside with your order like and i
can imagine if you say that with just
the slightest accent or you say that too
fast or you say that like and the person
picks up or they don't answer
you know like how much phone confusion
is probably going on there and so when
he calls me
he literally sounds like an automotive
an automaton or whatever
yeah he goes hi it's
i don't know his name hi it's john from
la cafe
i'm outside with your order and i'm like
is this a recorded
like message it's like it's almost like
a recorded message
like news anchors how they have a
specific kind of like vocalization
because of that same reason so it can be
you know as accessible as possible right
yeah but it's it's like he yeah it's
like
he's a news anchor local right
yeah you know yeah so anyways
if you're in town and you're looking for
that that hot chicken at 3am
i don't know why i'm advertising like
cafe right now nikola
with a handpan please is steve couch
still
an anchor here at ktla hey steve are you
still an anchor at ktla
let us know let us know in the comments
below come over and teach us how to talk
like a newscast yeah
that's actually kind of interesting that
would be super interesting you went to
high school with me and jake
and he's just like you know he's another
film dude like us he ended up becoming a
newscaster out here in los angeles for
ktla yeah
and the thing is you know growing up
he's just like us you're like hey guys
what's up oh i'm steve kush it was like
out here he talks like this yeah now
he's like i'm steve kuge
from ktla back to you maria he came by
for a shoot one time we shot with him
for something i forget what
yeah i thought it was cool vision but he
was yeah his division and he definitely
had like that classic like news anchor
uh not aesthetic but like vibe
yeah yeah yeah like and how he talked is
very like
not like so yep
it's effortless yeah intentional he also
he also was doing a live interview or a
live report one time
on on a location and some crazy person
like ran up to him
and he they like ran into him like
directly
at him and in order to defend himself he
knows karate and he like blocked the
person
and like punched him and then threw him
down
it was the coolest smoothest thing i've
ever seen he was the season of our own
video star for like a few days yeah
yeah all right play us out i'm just
thinking about steve
i didn't really know you that well in
high school though i think we were
acquainted
i hope i wasn't mean i was kind of mean
to people back then
either way i'm glad that you're a news
anchor i hope you're doing well
[Music]
and i hope that you're reporting on
alligators right now
[Music]
i want to see that newscast all right
thanks for watching